foreign
[Music]
changed the game of comedy by moving us
all [__] out here
to Austin Texas one of my best friends
one of my favorite comedians it's
[__] Joe Rogan
a whole week later and Joe Rogan's
comedy mothership is still the center of
attention in the comedy news world after
officially opening their doors last
Tuesday since the big debut the comedy
Mothership has put on a show almost
every single day of the week including
drop-ins from Bert Kreischer Tim Dillon
and Ron White but nothing as comedy fans
more excited than the first ever
recording of kill Tony at the comedy
Mothership happening tonight March 13th
with this type of monumental comedy
event happening today in Texas I felt
like it wasn't enough just to speculate
on what's going on over there the great
people tuning in to joke world for their
comedy news deserve all the best
information possible so we have a local
Austin comedian Chandler Rhone reporting
live outside the comedy Mothership right
now to give us all a closer look at
what's happening Chandler welcome to the
show thank you for being with us here
today please tell us what's it look like
out there the scene leading up to the
first ever kill Tony at Joe Rogan's club
uh everyone seems really excited Jake uh
everyone seems to be lining up there's a
huge line out here outside lots of
comics from all over the place from
Canada and New York just from all over
just trying to sign up for this show uh
the energy seems very great eight people
who seem very excited and I think people
really want to see what it's like to be
on the main stage of this new great
comedy venue now as far as you can tell
are there any people out there trying to
scalp or sell tickets as far as I can
tell Jake no one here is uh trying to
scout tickets or anything like that if
anything I feel like the uh the crew
here at the mothership I kind of came in
a watch out for that so people don't get
scammed out of uh this uh great show
that they're about to put on here for
kill Tony and Chandler you're a local
comedian yourself in Austin what's the
scene like what's the vibe in the comedy
community with this big news The Joe
Rogan Comedy Club opening and receiving
a lot of national attention I believe
everyone's really excited I think it
gives people a really great opportunity
to get on to this show I think people
um are really just trying to show what
they've got and people seem very very
excited would you stab somebody for a
spot tonight I would stab everyone in
this line for out for two minutes wow
wow you heard it here first dude Jake
people are out here willing to kill to
get into this Comedy Club hi Jake I'm
here on the scene with my last Wayne
um Eliza what do you how do you feel
about kill Tony and uh it being at the
mother show for the first time in it
opening
uh
I feel the same I guess Charles Adams Jr
uh Charles how do you feel about this uh
you know this first kill Tony on a
Monday at the comedy Mothership uh man
it's all good my feet hurt I wish they
give us some chairs or something would
you stab a guy for a chair I will [__] a
dude up right here on 6th Street right
here for a [__] chair I would
hard too yeah everyone's saying they
would stab for a chair right now or just
stab people to get in uh
I wouldn't stab anybody man just just
straight hands you know what I mean wow
that's a real man right there yeah just
[__] crush him you know what I mean I
totally understand you Charles you don't
feel like anything in your life has
changed or do you feel like you're gonna
get any opportunities out of this
I feel exactly the same I feel how I
always feel that's just how I feel all
the time I could be getting my dick
sucked right now and I'd feel the same
yeah I was actually talking to some
people on this line and they said that
uh most people on this line had the same
dick size as this microphone
Yeah Austin is full of honkies so that's
probably true I haven't seen many Asians
though right on well Jake I've
interviewed quite a few people uh people
seem very excited it sounds like people
would stab people uh which you know what
that's fair you know I mean the show is
called kill Tony uh as you can see
there's a lot of people in this line
people are very excited and are
anticipating the arrival of the show in
this club uh you know we're gonna see
how it goes and I also signed up myself
so uh we'll see how it goes well
Chandler that was some great information
thank you again for coming on the show
today you guys can find him on Instagram
his name is Chandler Roan also in last
week's comedy news update we reported on
the possibility of kill Tony moving to
twice a week now we are still waiting on
official confirmation there but what I
can say for sure is this Sunday
kiltony's having a special pop-up show
at the mothership so either way this
club's already leading to more kill Tony
the first Oscar since last year's Chris
Rock Will Smith slap took place last
night apparently Jimmy Kimmel hosted
this year and started off the Night by
addressing slap in his opening monologue
if anyone in this theater commits an act
of violence at any point during the show
you will be awarded the Oscar for best
actor
all right
[Applause]
and permitted to give a 19-minute long
speech
no but seriously the academy has a
crisis team in place if anything
unpredictable or violent happens during
the ceremony just do what you did last
year nothing
Aaron do absolutely nothing I kind of
can't believe I'm saying this but hats
off to Jimmy Kimmel for actually
roasting Will Smith and all the
Hollywood actors who applauded him last
year I honestly could have seen him
taking either side so that's pretty cool
now that the Chris Rock special is
finally out and Will Smith is banned
from attending the next nine Oscars it
seems like this bizarre story is slowly
coming to an end and I don't know about
you guys but now that the dust is
settled I think Chris Rock is clearly
the winner in all this I know this isn't
technically related to the stand-up
world but perhaps the greatest comedy
Scott show to ever exist in any realm of
the Universe I think you should leave
has announced season 3 will debut on
Tuesday May 30th you dig that slickback
that's pushback
I think you should leave Great Escape
yes can't wait for season three in other
words now Netflix will have triples if I
think you should leave triples makes it
safe now triple is his best guest spots
from last week your mom's house had on
Duncan Trussell two bears one cave was
Tom and David Cross kill Tony tonight is
with Chris De Stefano flagrant had on
Chael Sonnen Rachel Feinstein was a
guest on stavy's world Francis Alice was
on Matt and Shane's secret podcast and
Mark Norman was on the boys cast when
everyone was smashing grabbing
everything in 2021 or whatever it was
did you go check it out I did it in uh
2005 with Katrina Katrina hit everybody
looted and they're like these black
people are out of control and I'm like
yeah I'm holding like two plasmas you
know this girl I had a crush on she was
like I'm gonna go to the Superdome and
help and I was like I'll go with you oh
you went to hell I went to help and then
he's looting and helping yes I got a lot
of rain gotta balance it out you know
and so this they were like okay you got
to take this old guy and like be in
charge to him he was like 900 years old
and he needed help [__] so I had to
help him [__] and I had to wipe his ass
and I'm like no I do it again so I had
to wipe this old guy he thought you were
gonna be like ladling suit for people
exactly and now you're literally wiping
a guy I was gonna be doing puppet shows
we went in together and she was like off
with the women I had to help the old guy
and I was like I'm not even hanging out
with her this is a bummer and so I I
didn't get laid you don't even get laid
well I [__] the old guy
this past weekend with Theo Vaughn had
on funny Marco The Joe Rogan Experience
also talked with drunken Trussell
whiskey ginger head on Jason Nash and
finance was on the Honeydew Harry Mack
was on take your shoes off with Rick
Glassman the already garbage boys were
on we might be drunk Joe list was on you
know what dude with Robert Kelly Chrissy
chaos had on Rory and Maul and by far
the episode of the week Alex Jones was a
guest on the Tim Dylan show as far as
new stand-up specials go Bert Kreischer
Razzle Dazzle comes out on Netflix
tomorrow big Jay oakerson dog belly
comes out on YouTube April 5th which has
plenty of big J fans stoked to see his
special and there's a brand new stand up
on the spot with Jeremiah Watkins
premiering tonight on YouTube
foreign
that does it for this week's joke World
comedy news update as always thank you
so much for watching this episode and
we'll be back again next Monday with
some more comedy news I'm curious to see
in the comments how many of you guys are
also excited for season three if I think
you should leave I gotta assume that you
guys would also love that show speaking
of you guys though thank you so much for
getting joke world to 200 000
subscribers that is awesome that is
[__] cool as hell uh it's just you
know I say it all the time but this is
truly the best group the best community
of Comedy fans anywhere on the internet
and it's just so cool to see every week
all of us grow stronger together and
just continue moving forward and making
a niche in comedy where we can all you
know talk about the news talk about all
our favorite comedians all in one place
like you guys say the sports center for
comedy thank you so much it's awesome so
here's the 300K uh we got two more
videos coming out this week so make sure
to turn on your post notifications
click that Bell or go to hell I ca that
was terrible I can't believe I said that
thank you for 200k thank you for
watching this video
let's end it
[Music]